[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo au sommaire de ce
vendredi 6 décembre
la crue du soir on réfléchisse et au
transport du futur à l'école
d'ingénieurs installé à montigny le
bretonneux l'estac à une réunion en
présence notamment de responsables de la
sncf et de la ratp
plus de huit cent mille manifestants
dans toute la france selon le ministère
de l'intérieur et de nombreuses
perturbations pour cette grève
interprofessionnelle de 5 décembre avec
notre invité frédéric juillet
administrateur au medef 78 ou par
laurine l'organisation des entreprises
des réfugiés tibétains accueilli à
villepreux un nouveau siège social
inauguré pour la caf des yvelines et à
33e édition du téléthon qui démarre nous
reviendrons sur l'essentiel de
l'actualité de la semaine dans votre
département
lowrie le transport du futur une
certitude pour les acteurs du transport
ferroviaire
une conférence était organisée mercredi
soir à l'esstic l'estac à l'école
d'ingénieurs installé à montigny le
bretonneux une soirée des changes sur la
question en présence de responsables
sncf et ratp
mélanie poké comment transporter des
milliers de personnes sur l'ensemble de
l'île de france au moment des jeux
olympiques
comment gérer des déplacements nombreux
les évolutions technologiques et de
transport devront voir le jour comme à
saint quentin en yvelines
supra ouais c'était 7 1 pour nous c'est
un modèle idéal pour justement résoudre
nobreux des problèmes évoqués qui sont
entre autres la possibilité d'avoir un
transport trait sur 24 heures sur 24
autonome c'est une mamie qui se trouve à
grande échelle qui aussi en parler avec
le grand paris express typiquement c'est
des grands projets qui sont
autant bénéfique pour les jeux
olympiques que pour les parisiens à
terme les franciliens terme le transport
de foule sujet de prédilection dalenc
rakovic directeur général de sncf
transilien invité principal de la
conférence organisée par l'estac a
transporté aujourd'hui 3,5 millions de
voyageurs par jour en fait on est le
deuxième système de mass transit de
ferries du monde derrière tokyo
mais on sait que l'île de france va
encore augmenter et puis on s'est
finalement qu'on a besoin de
s'intéresser aussi aux autres mégapoles
dans le monde dans 60 ans on aura des
mégapoles de 80 millions d'habitants et
notre conviction c'est que aujourd'hui
le ferroviaire peut répondre à ce défi à
l'estaca la filière ferroviaire est
présente depuis 25 ans une quarantaine
d'étudiants la composent chaque année la
conférence était une occasion de
susciter des vocations
on considère que globalement
il ya à peu près 50% des métiers de les
cinq à dix prochaines années qui
n'existe pas encore donc on essaie
d'anticiper ce mouvement et donner une
orientation très très orientée vers le
futur
le transport ferroviaire est aujourd'hui
encore en mutation avec des projets
comme l'hyper loupe qui vise le
transport guidé jusqu'à 1200 km heure
[Musique]
huit cent mille manifestants dont 65
milles à paris selon le ministère de
l'intérieur jeudi 5 décembre des
transports largement perturbé de
nombreux services publics impact et une
mobilisation qui se poursuit ce vendredi
surtout dans les transports plus de 30
350 km de bouchons enregistré peu avant
8 heures sur les routes d'île de france
moins de 10% de grévistes chez les
enseignants selon le ministre de
l'éducation jean michel blanquer
ils étaient 51 15 % dans le primaire et
42,32 % dans le secondaire jeudi
l'unsa ratp principal syndicat de la
ratp a déjà annoncé la reconduction de
la grève jusqu'à lundi inclus et
l'intersyndicale appelle mardi à une
nouvelle journée d'action
interprofessionnelle
le secrétaire d'état auprès du ministère
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse a annoncé recevoir l'ensemble
des partenaires sociaux dès lundi même
annonce de la part d' agnès buzyn
ministre de la santé qui assurent les
recevoir en compagnie de jean paul
delevoye
le haut commissaire chargé de la réforme
des retraites et au niveau local aussi
que les mobilisations continuer à
versailles sous l'égide des cheminots de
la cgt
200 personnes ont défilé jeudi dans les
rues entre la gare de versailles
chantiers où le poste d'aiguillage est
restée fermée et le château de
versailles
ce vendredi matin à partir de 4 heures
une quarantaine de cheminots a bloqué
également le dépôt des véhicules du
réseau des bus qui dessert la cité
royale mais aussi vélizy et s'en sert
l'école
conséquence une vingtaine de lignes
n'ont pas pu circuler en heures de
pointe
la situation s'est débloquée à partir de
9h propos recueillis par grégory canal
est à la fois pour bloquer la
circulation des bus dans versailles en
complémentarité avec nous la paralysie
des transports
aussi pour interpeller les salariés de
fébus keolis filiale de la sncf c'est
pas rien les interpellés pour leur dire
que ben comme nous comme travailleur de
ratp comme tous les travailleurs en
france qui sont en grève en ce moment et
bien qu'ils sont visés par cette réforme
que
on sera nuisible et qu'il faut qu'ils se
mobilisent donc c'est effectivement
essayé d interpeler parler de la
question de la grève de la nécessité de
rentrer dans le mouvement tous ensemble
afin de pouvoir faire reculer le
gouvernement
autre action locale pour ceux qui n'ont
pas trouvé de place dans les bus
affrétés par les syndicats pour
acheminer les militants et finnois vers
la capitale jeudi à guyancourt une
vingtaine d'enseignants s'est mobilisée
dans la matinée devant la direction
académique des yvelines
un lieu symbolique pour montrer leur
désaccord sur le projet de loi
quelques salariés du secteur privé ont
également rejoint le mouvement propos
recueillis par aurélie ruiz si on a fait
ce geste là aujourd'hui ici c'est
justement pour pallier à cette
problématique de transport sur paris
pour pouvoir être visible et montrer que
finalement beaucoup de gens ne sont pas
d'accord à cette retraite là qui nous
est annoncé tout simplement
mais je pense que tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que pour l'instant
telle qu'elle est présentée elle n'est
pas à notre avantage ni
permettrait pas d'avoir une retraite
honorable et respectable par rapport à
ce conflit une grève qui est demandée
qui a également des conséquences sur les
commerces vides les noix et notamment
ceux situés à proximité des gares
le 5 décembre a été une journée
difficile pour ces enseignes
reportage de michael et demi d'euros
patrick chan de 10 minutes avec la voix
de grégory canale situation inédite dans
la gare de saint quentin en yvelines
deux commerces ont décidé de fermer
leurs portes ce 5 décembre faute de
clients ces circonstances ont profité à
cette enseigne les gérants s'attendait
pourtant à perdre un tiers de leurs
clients si on n'est pas là les gens ils
sont pas contents nos clients et puis
après les autres s'ils étaient très
contents que nous on était là parce que
le café chaud croissants pains au
chocolat chaud ça leur fait du bien
en attendant le train un peu plus loin
de la gare dans cette brasserie le bilan
est moins positif l'établissement a
perdu 50 % de clients sur la journée un
coup dur pour ce gérant qui a repris la
structure en 2018 et qui embauche trois
personnes et journée déjà mont asama
impacté que il moi je vois l'avenir du
voit demain après demain qu'est ce que
ça va donner moi la banque comptait gili
prélèvement qui prélèvent moi il
m'appelle pas s'il ya de l'argent il n'y
a pas de l'argent dedans dans le canton
donc il faut que je paye mes charges
faut que je prenne mes employés moi
j'aimerais bien qu aura une solution
d'autres commerces ont limité la casse
c'est le cas de ce bar restaurant qui
attire une clientèle d'entreprises sur
la journée sur le temps de midi la
structure a perdu 35 à 40 couverts sur
140 servi habituellement j'ai eu
plusieurs patrons d'entreprises
ou chefs de service qui m'ont dit que
leur équipe était en télétravail donc un
impact importante mais bon ça nous pose
pas un problème énorme la semaine
prochaine les commerces pourraient être
de nouveau touché la grève devrait durer
au moins jusqu'au lundi 9 décembre
frédéric gillier vous êtes avec nous vos
jours jours alors vous êtes peut-être
partie du conseil d'administration du
medef 78 quelles sont les répercussions
d'un tel mouvement sur les commerces là
sur le reportage qu'on a vu il est
évident que les commerces ont fortement
touché
ce qui paraît logique puisque ils sont
situés au niveau des gares donc si à
plus d'usagé bayer plus de clients
effectivement là c'est ça reste
effectivement très problématique
la question après c'est de savoir
combien de temps va durer le mouvement
donc je pense qu'une journée après c'est
tout à fait gérable dans le temps ça va
être plus compliqué - carrément fermé
j'imagine c'est pas du tout le cas de
tous les commerces des yvelines sur une
journée comme celle ci n'ont bien
entendu alors collègues pour les
commerçants j'irai sur une journée
l'impact il est il est relativement
limitée dont pour ceux qui ne sont pas
en tout cas aux abords d'une gare qui
pour un commerçant qui est située dans
une rue commerçante où dans un an un
quartier on va dire en coeur de ville
effectivement l'impact sur le de la
grève sur le commerce et les quasi
transparent en fait sur une journée
c'est la grève perdure on est au mois de
décembre
j'imagine que ça doit inquiéter quand
même à la grève perdure oui plus de
trains est ce que ça reste ensuite
cantonné aux usagers est ce que ça va
toucher un moment donné la marche des
marchandises ou pas après tous les
scénarios tous les scenarii sont
possibles pour l'instant on va pas
prévoir
on veut le grand soir puisque on n'est
qu'au début du mouvement dans tous les
cas alors on a dû laisser les clients
viennent pas les salariés aussi peuvent
avoir des difficultés l'entreprise en
tma antemeta à guyancourt a procédé à
des aménagements incitation au
covoiturage télétravail flexibilité
horaire et même des nuits d'hôtel
défrayer reportage de mathilde 2010 garé
sur le parking
pierre-yves a trouvé la solution pour ne
pas rester bloqué dans les bouchons le
soir il est venu en vannes pour jamais
de prier au dépourvu et véhicules 95
j'ai vécu 90 mhz
plus ces épisodes neigeux sur sur
guyancourt qui sont pas neutres cette
ère que j'ai des collègues et qui ont
été amenés à dormir ici donc quitte à
faire autant être autonome et pouvoir
dormir
y compris sur la route pour cette
journée de grève
l'entreprise antemeta a tout prévu
télétravail nuits d'hôtel covoiturage
tout est mis à disposition pour
faciliter les déplacements des salariés
on s'est renseigné auprès de saint
quentin en yvelines auprès de la sncf
auprès même des aéroports pour contrôler
y avoir un état du trafic et ensuite on
l'a communiqué le collaborateur les
prévisions de circulation les prévisions
de train de fermeture de grève et écoles
on leur a demandé de se rapprocher de
leur mairie dans l'entreprise 45
employés sous tente et travail soit plus
de la moitié
même si les machines à café sont moins
sollicitées rhône on a quand même
souhaité venir grâce à l'aménagement de
son planning
la flexibilité horaire ça permet aussi
de ne pas lier pour certains et mais
pour moi dans mon cas précis sur les
garderies ou les centres qui peuvent
être âpre en effectif réduit
arthur responsable informatique est
venue en voiture ce matin
et contrairement à d'habitude il n'a eu
aucun ralentissement sur la route même
s'il a pris quelques dispositions il
craint les prochains jours cette
disposition elles sont ponctuels et que
si ça continue sur plus d'une semaine je
pense qu'après ça va devenir compliqué
si la grève est reconduite l'entreprise
antemeta gardera les mêmes aménagements
pour ses salariés s'étaient résignés
comment les entreprises entreprises
peuvent-elles s'organiser pour leurs
employés de manière très simple sur une
journée encore une fois il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises j'ai appelé mes collègues
entrepreneurs et le télétravail par une
solution aujourd'hui qui est largement
développé dans les entreprises sur les
postes administratifs sur les postes on
va dire sédentaires commerciaux qui se
passe beaucoup par téléphone donc
effectivement le télétravail est une
solution
d'autres chefs d'entreprises des mêmes
des salariés ont utilisé les rtt
possible pour éviter
avec la crainte d'avoir des bouchons
force est de constater que finalement
sur les routes ça roulait plutôt pas
trop mal donc finalement il ya beaucoup
de salariés qui sont déplacés qui
étaient contents puisque on évite les
bouchons donc on gagne du temps on gagne
du temps dans les transports et donc
j'ai beaucoup de mes salariés seront
élevés plutôt zen finalement puisqu'il
n'avait pas les transports et les aléas
des bouchons lundi la grève risque de
perdurer au moins jusqu'à lundi niveau
transport comment s'organiser d'ici là
je pense que les entreprises
ce que j'en vois ce que je vis au
quotidien sont quand même relativement
compatissante et on est tous prêts à
faire des efforts et si un retard on
sera largement compréhensifs
ensuite le pourquoi pas du covoiturage
si vraiment il ya plus de transport
mais à titre personnel par exemple je
sais que j'ai un véhicule de livraison
voire plusieurs qui peut servir les
chercher les salariés qui sont vraiment
commencer quelque part donc les
entreprises sont prêtes à tout pour
effectivement aider leurs salariés avait
retravaillé
alors maintenant vous allongez la
gestion du mouvement j'aimerais revenir
sur sa génèse à savoir le projet de
réforme des retraites
commandé par le haut commissaire jean
paul delevoye quel regard porte levée
des sur cette réforme salue-t-il déjà
réformé recommencer ça c'est une
excellente question
j'aurais tendance à dire oui d'ailleurs
c'est aussi ce que pense le medef est ce
que dit le medef ce que dit le président
roubaisien
c'est très simple qu'on le veuille ou
non en 2025 va y avoir un trou dans tous
les cas qui va être compris entre 7 et
10 7 milliards selon ce qui va se passer
dans l'est dans les prochains mois donc
il est évident qu'on doit agir et
trouver des solutions
donc après ce type de solution le
gouvernement s'y attachent et pour
l'instant il est entre guillemets en
consultation ait encore aucune décision
de prise
on est juste dans le dans les phases
préliminaires du projet de loi dans tous
les cas alors le président du medef
geoffroy roux de bézieux s'est exprimé
sur l'âge pivot qu'il juge comme étant
la mesure la plus équilibrée les
salariés partant avant cet âge subir une
décote de leurs pensions anas qui
pourrait être fixé à 64 ans s'est adapté
à l'écouté encore une fois l'entreprise
s'adapte c'est le propre du chef
d'entreprise et de l'entrepreneuriat ont
fait fi de la loi enfants en disant la
loi qu'elle soit bonne ou pas dans tous
les cas il faut l'appliquer
la loi c'est la loi la loi 2
du départ en retraite à 64 ans le fameux
âge pivot que préconise le medef semble
justement un challenge intéressant pour
sauver si on peut le sauver encore ce
serait bien de notre système est quand
même assez unique au monde
et du coup ça obligera aussi
l'entreprise à s'adapter par rapport à
des salariés qui sont qui vieillissent
force est de constater qu'à 64 on n'est
pas non plus ou à 60 ans on né peut on
vieillit on n'est pas vieux au point de
ne plus travailler
donc ça oblige aussi l'entreprise et le
salarié à voir comment par exemple sur
un métier manuel
on peut transformer ce métier manuel et
peut-être donner un autre sens au métier
que j'exerce à 1 par exemple un
manutentionnaire
peut-être que ce manutentionnaire il va
faire un peu moins de manutention et
qu'on appelle on va peut-être utilisé ce
savoir-faire du halage à l'expérience
pour aller former les plus jeunes et du
coup ça peut être un beau challenge en
interne pour pour utiliser les
ressources qu'ils vieillissent mais qui
sont pour le coup très intéressante et
très utile pour une entreprise
donc ça nécessite peut être un autre
regard sur sur l'emploi qui me pas aussi
intéressant c'est un peu ma prochaine
question final cette réforme qu'est-ce
qu'elles pourraient changer pour
l'entreprise
exactement ce que j'aime dire mais si on
va plus loin mais j'ai un salarié qui
vient boire un dit à monsieur gibier je
vais partir en retraite
est-ce que vous accepteriez que je reste
un peu parce que parce que j'ai peur de
m'ennuyer chez moi il ya quand même des
gens qui encore une fois soit 104 on
n'ait pas lieu il ya quand même beaucoup
la majorité des salariés aiment
travailler et aiment bien leur travail
et effectivement le départ en retraite
est aussi un facteur angoissant de
savoir qu'est ce que je vais faire
demain
donc le fait de dire
il faut s'adapter en fait aux nouvelles
conditions moi je pense aussi à la
jeunesse enfin aux jeunes qui arrivent
sur le marché du travail
écoute aura pas de retraite si on
continue comme ça donc c'est assez
motivant de trouver les ressources
nécessaires pour pouvoir rebondir sur
toujours le même système mais peut-être
avec des visions différentes
on arrive à la fin de cet entretien
merci frère est gelée d'être venu sur
notre plateau vous le rappelle vous êtes
membre de conseil d'administration du
medef 78 on ferme cette page consacrée à
la réforme des retraites et aux
mobilisations et on passe on reste de
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
direction villepreux des réfugiés
tibétains sont arrivés lundi mardi dans
la commune sur décision de la préfecture
cette mesure fait suite à l'évacuation
d'un campement dans la forêt de saint
germain en laye et séjourneront pendant
un peu plus d'un mois sur une partie du
gymnase alain mimoun
les détails avec michael et demi d'euros
leur bus les a déposés aux alentours de
14 heures au gymnase alain mimoun de
villepreux ce mardi 3 des 191 réfugiés
tibétains sont arrivés dans la commune
en provenance d'un campement de fortune
situé à achères un site évacué par la
préfecture un peu plus tôt dans la
matinée
maintenant je me sens mieux parce que
nous n'avions pas de maison la nuit
faisait vraiment très froid on est très
très très content on est très satisfait
on remercie vraiment toutes les
personnes qui ont contribué à la
victoire en fait parce que c'est une
victoire quand même pour nous à leur
arrivée les réfugiés ont été accueillis
avec un thé chaud et des biscuits par
une vingtaine d'habitants de la commune
venus bénévolement un élan de solidarité
qui a commencé via un service de
messagerie instantanée dimanche dernier
beaucoup de villes provient se sont
mobilisés actuellement on est à peu près
70 qui ont souhaité donc venir en aide
sur la logistique les repas la
convivialité éventuellement les inviter
chez nous de temps en temps pendant la
durée de leur séjour dans la commune
certaines activités associatives de la
ville ont dû être déplacés sur d'autres
sites
la première des choses c'est qu'en tant
que maire on a une crainte très égoïste
on se dit mais comment je vais faire
pour que la ville continue de
fonctionner il ya une très forte
collaboration de l'ensemble des
associations qui étaient impactés tout
simplement pour se mettre en phase qui
va aller ou pas ce que c'est vrai qu'on
perd quand même une salle majeur donc il
fallait qu'on replace les associations
dans la ville les réfugiés devrait
rester jusqu'au 5 janvier dans la
commune ils seront deux nouveaux
déplacés dans une autre ville après
cette date
cela fait un an qu'elle est installée
dans le nouveau quartier des chantiers à
versailles après avoir quitté
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise la caf
des yvelines a inauguré officiellement
mardi ses nouveaux locaux l'organisme
privé qui gère le versement des aides
sociales et familiales dispose de six
mille mètres carrés d'espacé pour ses
300 collaborateurs
un accès plus un pas deux pas de la gare
de versailles chantiers et un accueil du
public repenser bbox dédié au
rendez-vous un espace numérique
fonctionner les 24 postes en libre accès
pour effectuer ces démarches à
l'extérieur enfin une borne interactive
pour consulter son dossier allocataires
à tout moment propos recueillis par
patrick jacques de dixmude
nous avons choisi cette date
anniversaire pour accueillir nos
partenaires et puis effectivement
souligné toute la qualité de vie que
nous avons depuis que nous sommes ici
depuis un an donc qualité de vie
d'accueil pour nos allocataires ce sont
plus de 16000 personnes qui sont qui ont
été accueillis à la caf des yvelines
depuis depuis un an
nous sommes pleinement dans notre
logique d'accessibilité pour nous pour
nos publics avec un accueil totalement
rénové moderne et en conformité avec la
stratégie d'accueil des allocataires
c'est à dire du rendez vous mais
également de l'accès libre à des espaces
de multimédia un projet de réaménagement
du carrefour de la mer me donne situé
dans l'intersection de la verrière beau
repas et coignières depuis le 18
novembre il est soumis à la concertation
mercredi soir se tenait un atelier de
travail à coignières les habitants des
communes concernées sont invités à
donner leurs années auprès d'un gérant
de la concertation une réunion de
restitution de se tiendra le 12 décembre
à maurepas médiature possibilité de
s'exprimer auprès de la direction des
routes ile-de-france
jusqu'au 20 décembre le maire que je
suis est plutôt satisfait en effet que
l'état ait repris à son compte ce projet
et qui nous propose aujourd'hui une
concertation publique sur le sujet mais
il est évident qu'il faut
en contrepartie que les habitants aussi
soit entendu que les commerçants soient
entendus pour faire le projet gelé dire
le plus
réalisa possible mais le plus en
adéquation avec ce que nous souhaitons
la 33e édition du téléthon se déroule
les 6 et 7 décembre l'occasion de
relever des défis solidaire le club de
plongée de saint quentin en yvelines
en lançant en pratiquant d'apnée il
propose aussi une découverte de leur
activité mélanie poquet les a rencontrés
le monde du silence jusque dans une
piscine un calme apparent qui demande un
peu de travail de concentration
rendu célèbre en 1988 avec le film de
luc besson
l'apnée est pratiqué par le club de
saint quentin en yvelines
l'apnée c'est prendre conscience qu'on
est que l'être humain est capable de
faire des choses que le mental pense
qu'il peut pas faire on apprend une
respiration spéciale pour les apnéistes
que toute pratique tous les apnéistes et
on apprend surtout à se détendre
le maître mot pour le téléthon les
analystes se lanceront un challenge
réaliser un maximum de longueur de 25
mètres pendant six heures à la piscine
salvador allende des clayes-sous-bois
pour l'apnée c'est un petit peu
particulier parce que les gens qui vont
participer doivent avoir un
minimum de niveau rappeneau on peut pas
se permettre pour des raisons de
sécurité de faire venir n'importe quelle
personne
il y aura également
la plongée donc il va y avoir des
baptêmes organisé également de la nage à
l'âge classique en surface donc le défi
est lancé pour le samedi 7 décembre dès
14 heures les dons seront reversés à
l'afm téléthon et plusieurs communes se
mobilisent à saint quentin en yvelines à
l'occasion du téléthon 2010 9 le
programme deuxième édition à coignières
avec animation le samedi au gymnase
soirée country rock le samedi soir et
concert gospel le dimanche à villepreux
l'événement est bien maintenue au
complexe alain mimoun et ce même avec
l'accueil de réfugiés tibétains
certaines activités pourrait se dérouler
toutefois à l'école le clos crozatier
le téléthon est très sportif du côté de
montigny le bretonneux challenge atelier
lancers-francs marche nocturne 30 heures
à vivre au centre sportif pierre de
coubertin
enfin à voisins le bretonneux les 30
heures seront axés autour d'un fil rouge
un voyage dans le temps
l'association les belles vies sinoise
partage sa passion pour les voitures de
collection et vous pouvez retrouver une
édition spéciale du 7-8 loisirs consacré
au téléthon en replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
maintenant on passe à notre case
l'actualité en ile de france
[Musique]
à notre-dame l'heure n'est toujours pas
à la restauration huit mois après
l'incendié la consolidation de l'édifice
poursuit opération la plus délicate le
retrait de lennon échafaudage monté
autour de la flèche avant l' incendie
que le brasier a déformé et sous des
reportages de nos confrères et à grand
paris une poignée de main entre valérie
pécresse et monseigneur au petit
archevêque de bas ils viennent de signer
une convention entre la région ile de
france et la fondation notre dame
elle prévoit un soutien financier son
montant 10 millions d'euros le fonds
cathédrale de paris mise en place après
l' incendie a déjà recueilli 49 millions
d'euros
pour eux c'est effectivement 49 millions
y compris la somme qui a été versée
aujourd'hui et nous avons 370 millions
de promesses de pions et donc ces
promesses sont effectives c'est pas des
promesses 370 millions en tout c'est à
dire avec les grands donateurs qui avec
lesquels j'ai signé une convention donc
voilà où nous en sommes aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui l'heure n'est pas encore à
la restauration la priorité c'est la
consolidation les normes échafaudages
installés avant l' incendie doit être
démonté une grue de 100 mètres de haut
permettra de descendre une à une les
pièces de la structure
on peut pas le retirer comme un
échafaudage classique puisque ça brûlait
donc il va y avoir un centrage déjà fou
d'âge qui est là un échafaudage par
dessus et des cordistes qui vont
descendre donc tout ça va demander
beaucoup beaucoup de temps beaucoup de
courage aussi pour ceux qui vont et puis
aussi toutes les travaux de
consolidation de vérification des
pierres des joints des pierres etc
puisqu'on ne sait pas si la volt est
solide
il va falloir faire un dogme ce cas
extrêmement précis pour connaître le
coût financier de la restauration de
notre dame de paris
il faudra attendre le printemps 2020 en
attendant une enveloppe de 85 millions
d'euros a été déboursée pour consolider
l'édifice et c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de nous avoir suivi on se
quitte avec un extrait de la ménagerie
de verre la pièce aux quatre nominations
aux molières sera jouée à la salle
jacques brel à montigny le bretonneux le
10 décembre prochain retour de
l'actualité locale dès lundi avec le
street journal de grégory canale pour
une gaine sur tv 78 je suis le narrateur
de la pièce mais aussi à l'un de ses
personnages
les autres personnages sans ma mère à
landas
mais ce laura
et la jeune galerie qui apparaît dans
cette finale tu vas au cinéma de plus en
plus tu fais penser à ton père il
sortait jusqu'à pas d'heure sans aucune
explication puis un beau jour je suis
quand la compagnie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]